[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle simon j'ai 22 ans
et il ya quelques mois j'ai eu peur de
mourir en fait peur comme ça n'arrive
jamais alors que j'étais chez moi dans
mon appartement bordelais sans risque
apparent plus particulier que ça et
pourtant j'envisageais déjà le pire est
pour vous expliquer comment ça se fait
il faut nous parle de quelqu'un
probablement d'ailleurs une des
personnes que j'admire le plus
aujourd'hui charles c'est un gars de 28
ans que j'ai rencontré l'an dernier et
qui parcourt le monde pour couvrir
l'actualité chaude et aujourd'hui dans
quelque sorte le grand reporter de brut
dire je vous dis ça j'ai même pas si
vous connaissez brut c'est un média
d'information sur les réseaux sociaux
bref et moi comme on l'a dit je fais
juste des vidéos sur youtube donc on
s'est super bien entendus
et puis il m'a proposé de m'emmener sur
des missions pour réaliser des vidéos et
quand on connaît un peu
c'est impossible que je refuse ce genre
d'offre donc la toute première
expédition ce fut au tchad un pays assez
safe pour couvrir une recrudescence de
malnutrition infantile sévère aiguë donc
c'est des gosses qui crèvent de faim
c'est une crise humanitaire vraiment
grave alors là dessus chacun a un peu sa
sensibilité
moi personnellement ça allait à
supporter donc à n'djamena la capitale
tchadienne
tout s'est très bien passé lui la sortie
charles a sorti ses reportages moi j'ai
sorti ma vidéo et puis chacun est rentré
de son côté et quelques mois après cette
première expérience
il me rappelle pour rempiler alors je
sais pas si parmi vous certains ont déjà
entendu parler du nord kivu
c'est une région au nord-est de la
république démocratique du congo
parce que moi avant que charmant parle
au téléphone jean n'avait strictement
jamais entendu parler pour vous dire je
ne savais même pas que le congo et la
république démocratique du congo
c'était deux pays distincts j'étais
vraiment flinguer donc si je la prends à
quelqu'un ce soir je me sentirai déjà
beaucoup moins seul bref il m'explique
que c'est une des régions les plus
violentes au monde qu'il ya une très
forte instabilité dans la région pour
tout un tas de
raisons qui serait trop long de tout
vous énumérer ici et qu'il est assez
courant que des groupes armés se ramène
donc du coin ou d'ouganda se ramène et
commettent des massacres qu on est déjà
sur une ambiance relativement moyenne et
qu'en plus de ça parce que c'est pas
fini on allait couvrir a béni la plus
grosse ville du coin le travail d'alima
une ong présentes sur place qui
s'occupait de lutter tant bien que mal
contre une montée en force d'une des
quatre souches les plus violentes dans
des virus les plus les taux au monde
qu'on a tendance à avoir oublié ici en
europe
ebola zaïre ski dire déjà des centaines
de morts tout ça donc moi premier
réflexe comme vous l'auriez sûrement
tous fait google images nord-kivu
bon alors premières images ça ressemble
à ça jusque là ça va ça ressemble à ce
qu'on voit ce qu'on pourrait imaginer un
pays africain du style bon là c'est un
mec je l'écouté qui est relativement pas
au top là c'est plusieurs mecs qui sont
relativement pas au top
bon sacrée ambiance
vous l'aurez compris c'est là que j'ai
commencé à flipper comment vous décrire
cette sensation cette vraie soif de
découverte d' aventure d'apprendre
d'informer aussi vraiment et puis de
montrer sur tout mais baigné dans une
vraie peur de mourir alors y en a
sûrement qui vous dire que j'en fais
trop et que je leur ai juste eu à dire
non et je peux le comprendre mais faut
aussi se mettre en tête que ça faisait
des mois que j'attendais une opportunité
comme ça et quand elle s'est présentée
mais elle était beaucoup plus
impressionnante que tout ce que tout ce
à quoi je m'étais préparé et je me
souviens d'ailleurs encore à voir
charles au téléphone a essayé de trouver
du réconfort et lui me dire je suis
désolé vieux j'aimerais être le
promettre mais je peux pas de garantir
qu'on ne reviendra et sapho que le
comprennent avec le recul il avait
raison d'être aussi terre à terre alors
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup hésité j'en ai
pas parlé à ma mère de suite ma copine
ne savait pas non plus trop quoi me dire
et puis je crois que ça s'est fait un
peu sur un coup de tête j'ai fini par
envoyer mon passeport chez brut à paris
pour faire faire le visa là ça y est
c'est acté le doute c'est transformé en
en profond profond stress
d'autant plus que le voyage serait dans
quelques semaines mais quelque chose
s'est passé il était environ 18 heures
lorsque les premiers coups de feu ont
commencé à retentir d'abord aux abords
du camp militaire de kananga
puis les assaillants ont pris la
direction du centre ville
les civils ont tenté de fuir mais ils
ont été les premières cibles
au moins 14 personnes ont été tuées
parmi les forces de l'ordre
cinq militaires auraient perdu la vie
cette attaque est attribuée aux rebelles
des adf les forces démocratiques alliées
un groupe armé ougandais les rebelles
ont brûlé des maisons pillé des magasins
le marché central les quartiers pays d'à
moanda et bel air ont été vidée de ses
habitants
les attaques des adf ont fait des
centaines de morts depuis 2014
al'approche des élections cette
situation préoccupe la société civile de
béni compte observer une journée de
deuil ce lundi le bilan total
si je dis pas de bêtises s'est avéré
être un peu plus d'une vingtaine de
personnes dont une énorme majorité de
civils
et puis en plus dans des quartiers
touchés étaient vraiment très proche de
l'hôpital d'alma où je devais me rendre
donc là je vous avoue que ça commençait
à faire un petit peu beaucoup moi je
commence à reculer
chez brut on m'a fait comprendre à
charles qu'effectivement pour cette fois
ci le youtube heures mais peut-être
mieux qu'ils restent en france et
quelques jours plus tard je n'étais pas
dans l'avion qui décollait pour l'ère
des scènes alors j'étais assez frustré
et j'ai voulu en savoir plus sur l'adf
qui était ce type
keira fallait tout le monde dans le coin
donc l'adf c'est l'acronyme de allied
démocratique force ça c'est le drapeau
officiel
c'est une milice ougandaise rebelle qui
a été formé dans les années 90 en
opposition à ce monsieur
yoweri museveni président de l'ouganda
aujourd'hui ou sevegner toujours en
place comme vous l'aurez compris l'adf
existe toujours et en plus de 20 ans les
relations avec le gouvernement de rdc
ont-elles variés du soutien à
l'ignorance et ce qui est assez
impressionnant avec tout le temps qui
s'est écoulé c'est que les revendiquent
les revendications aussi bien politique
kate nique
de l'adf sont devenus de plus en plus
floue et transforme en une véritable
épée de damoclès qui frappe n'importe
quand et dans la stratégie complètement
imprévisible en fait en faisant des
recherches sur eux je crois que j'ai
compris d'où venait ma peur du nord kivu
c'était même pas tant ebola ni même
n'importe quelle maladie et on va dire
s'il y avait eu en conflit ouvert défini
là-bas entre deux états ou de force
ça n'aurait pas plus posé problème que
ça de me rendre non le vrai facteur
horrifique c'était l'inconnu que le
destin aurait pu frapper à ma porte à
n'importe quel moment sans que je ne
puisse l'anticiper sans raison sans que
je ne puisse le comprendre ni même avoir
aucun pouvoir dessus et vous savez quoi
en fait en y réfléchissant on est tous
fait de la même manière en france chaque
année
c'est en moyenne moins de dix personnes
qui décèdent dans des attentats
terroristes en comparaison l'alcool est
responsable de 49000 décès et le
tabagisme 78 minutes et je vais pas vous
faire l'affront de vous faire des
calculs comparatif plus poussé que ça
les morts sur la route en 2018 c'est
3259 tués et pourtant dans la salle suis
sûr que si je vous demande qui a peur de
prendre la voiture
pas grand monde va lever la main mieux
encore les automobilistes râlent quand
de nouveaux radars sont installés ou
quand la limite sur les routes à 90 est
abaissé à 80 km 1 c'est comme les
fumeurs qui peste quand le paquet se
rapproche inexorablement des 10 euros
mais pour ces dix morts d'un fanatique
chaque année des voix se font moins
entendre quand des lois liberticides
bien plus dures sont appliqués quand un
état d'urgence et doucement diluée à
lavau classique qu'il ya des discussions
sur instaurer des caméra à
reconnaissance faciale dans certains
événements ç'a vraiment été le cas à
nice pire les urnes finissent par parler
et témoigne d'une vraie peur
insoutenable d'une partie de la
population
en fait aujourd'hui
l'inconnue c'est le vrai fléau en
occident contrairement enfin
contrairement à l'alcoolisme du
tabagisme ou même à au cancer n'importe
quelle maladie chez nous désincarner
aussi peu efficace soit elle en
comparaison demeure imprévisible et
complètement extérieur à notre quotidien
ce sont en fait une des dernières part
d'inconnu avec de lourdes conséquences
que notre société n'a pas encore réussi
à éradiquer en occident l'imprévisible
n'existe plus le risque lié à l'inconnu
est mort il existe des assurances
littéralement pour tous vous pouvez
savoir le temps qu'il fera demain ou
même durant toute la semaine vous serez
à l'avance quelle sera leur est le
résultat des prochaines élections
présidentielles des mois al avance on va
pouvoir vous dire à peu près quand est
ce que va démarrer la prochaine crise
économique mondiale et sa violence ou
même quels seront les comètes qui parce
qu'on prenne notre planète dans des
millions d'années où la durée de vie
approximative du soleil en milliards
d'années ouais
notre société a tué l'inconnu je vous
apprendrai rien en plus en vous disant
que depuis chez vous vous pouvez savoir
à quoi ressemble l'arrière cour de la
plus perdue des bicoques au fin fond de
la campagne cambodgienne
non il est loin le temps où les nations
les empires garder jalousement leurs
nouvelles découvertes cartographique
comme ressource stratégique mais aussi
comme témoin de l'inconnu on allait même
jusqu'à écrire
là ce sont les dragons en bordure de
cartes dans les terrines tonita parce
qu'en fait ces fonds d'allemands humain
c'est fondamentalement humain de combler
l'inconnu de notre imaginaire et pour
peu qu'on en ait eu un aperçu un système
biologique vieux de plusieurs
millénaires conçu pour la survie nous
fait passer nos pensées probablement
plus dangereux et sombre que la réalité
ne l'est sûrement les scènes les plus
violentes psychologiquement cinéma sont
souvent celles finalement en contrechamp
parce que nous sommes des animaux
sociaux forget de croyance et dans une
dans une société qui misent de plus en
plus sur la peur comme moteur pour
capter son audience la peur
l'imprévisible devient un cauchemar qui
nous fait souvent faire de mauvais choix
nous maintenant qu'à davantage
d'ignorance d'ailleurs je parle je parle
mais je vous ai pas raconté du coup ce
qui est arrivé à charles parce que lui
il est parti au nord kivu tout seul il a
filmé les hôpitaux il a filmé les
malades des reportages d'ailleurs fin
des témoignages d'ailleurs très
important qu'il était nécessaire
d'entendre et de diffuser qu'il aurait
été dommage de terre et puis juste avant
de partir juste avant de quitter ce pays
et cette région il s'est passé un truc
il s'est vraiment passé un truc il faut
que je vous montre
ok donc ça c'est mon rêve depuis que je
suis tout petit
téléphone va bien les bonobos sont une
espèce de grands singes endémique de la
république démocratique du congo
ce que vous venez de voir est
probablement mon plus grand regret de ma
courte existence et à chaque fois que je
quitterais l'europe
ce visa seul dans mon passeport nues et
sans aucun tampon il est là nous
rappellera l'erreur que j'ai fait de ne
pas écouter la conviction et de laisser
croire que mes peurs domineront
l'expérience que je voulais vivre en
fait à ne jamais affronter l'inconnu on
transforme son unique vie en une
éternelle routine et je suis sûr que
encore une fois si je vous demande à
vous dans la salle de vous remémorer vos
meilleurs souvenirs des expériences qui
ont changé votre vie je suis prêt à
parier qu'elles ne sont pas pointés en
prévenant et l'idée que j'essaie de
faire passer pourrait se résumer à un
truc assez drôle c'était une phrase
écrite pour la première fois que j'ai lu
sur mon carnet de collège mon carnet de
correspondance ou le carnet d'agenda et
aujourd'hui c'est le type de phrase que
vous pourrez retrouver sur des groupes
de facebook de citations péter mais je
la trouve vraiment avec le temps
fondamentalement juste et vrai c'était
un truc qui disait comme le plus dur
dans tout c'est toujours de 6 m alors je
suis pas en train de vous dire accepter
tout temps d'aller dans les régions les
plus dangereuses du monde
sous le simple prétexte de lutter contre
vos peurs et de défier l'ignorance alors
pas du tout ça c'est mon ressenti
perso mais je sais que chacun d'entre
nous quelque part avant notre part
d'inconnu de peur fabrique et qui
n'attendent qu'à peut-être vous faire
rater une des plus grandes expériences
de vos vies qu'il s'agisse d'aller au
nord-kivu d'affronter le regard des
autres de repenser votre existence notre
monde chacun au fond de nous avons le
pouvoir d' éclairer nos zones sombres
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]